bonjour marine calme et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation après la
pollution de l'air et le climat l'état
fait désormais face à un recours sur la
biodiversité donc cette fois on se
souvient le conseil d'état début août a
condamné l'état à payer 10 millions
d'euros par semestre de retard d'une
action au niveau de la pollution d'air
qu'est ce que vous attendez cette fois
avec ce recours à ce que l'état peut-il
à nouveau être condamné
bonjour alors déjà faut préciser qu'il
s'agit pour nous un recours préalable
c'est à dire que c'est un recours
gracieux on demande à l'administration
de prendre des mesures pour lutter pour
la protection du leadership et l'état a
donc deux mois pour répondre aux
demandes des associations ou non et dans
ce cas là effectivement les invitations
pourront intervenir la justice pour
demander des mesures concrètes et si
vous obtenez bien qu est ce que ça peut
faire jurisprudence faire avancer les
choses ou bien ce que vous craignez que
ce ne soit qu'un coup d'épée dans l'eau
en gros est ce que la boîte de pandore
va-t-elle s'ouvrir
en gros il faut quand même pas rappeler
des l'autre j'avais 13 ans qui a
expliqué à part que malheureusement les
recourants 40 recule il y en a eu déjà
beaucoup
la france a été condamnée dans sa
gestion de la crise ils veulent du vert
couleur le blanc avait pas reniée par la
gestion de la pollution et énormément de
retours également en garante fautive le
problème critique n'est pas contraignant
le juge ne peut pas forcer l'état
finalement à asper et à agir pour la
protection de la nature il s'agit
vraiment d'une question extrêmement
politique et malheureusement dans ce
genre de situation est bien le juste
souvent l'homme du passé c'est à dire
que il juge parce qu'il n'a pas été jeté
mais c'est vraiment dans notre
république à la politique aux hommes et
aux femmes politiques d'agir et de
prendre de véritables d'étudiants il ya
eu la loi climat qui a été publié au
journal officiel le 24 août l'état agit
quand même de quoi accuser vous l'état
français exactement
là en l'occurrence les associations qui
le composent se recouvrent elles
agissent en pour 40 sous titres dans le
cadre de la lutte contre les pesticides
puisque tout est un engagement de
campagne de manuel macro qui n'a pas été
tenue il n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout et
la même réintroduit le nyko chino id est
donc évidemment on le sait aujourd'hui
des produits chimiques participe à la
destruction de la biodiversité et c'est
un problème parce que par cette
destruction nette de divers types et
évidemment c'est toute la chaîne du
vivant qui en pâtit et nous évidemment
aussi mais ce recours voilà il met aussi
en lumière le fait que la france n'a pas
d'engagement chiffré dans la protection
de la biodiversité
or la diversité elle ne dépend
évidemment pas plus le des pesticides
elle dépend aussi de l'artificialisation
des sols de la déforestation dépollution
plaît si des hausses de température dire
que vous pointez du doigt par exemple
les agriculteurs un scab la grille
bashing derrière
alors les agriculteurs il faut les aider
évidemment dans cette transition
aujourd'hui on voit que les politiques
agricoles qui font mis en place par la
france ne sont pas suffisantes par
exemple il ya vraiment une vraie
interrogation par rapport à
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché de
ses produits de ces pesticides qui sont
dangereux et d'amande pour
l'environnement mais aussi pour la santé
des agriculteurs et celle des
populations riveraines des épandages et
aujourd'hui on le voit il ya déjà des
recours qui aboutit et encore un
récemment puisque en juin 2021 la cour
administrative administrative d'appel de
lyon pardon a confirmé l'annulation de
l'autorisation ou sur les marchés du
roundup pro 360 pour non respect du
principe de précaution donc dû d'un
point de vue au dessus des autorisations
de mise sur le marché on le voit les
pesticides sont attaqué de tous les
côtés il ne s'agit pas d'aller contre
les agriculteurs il s'agit de protéger
l'enfant de 10 ans
8 cm va clore
son congrès mondial qui a lieu depuis
une semaine maintenant du côté de
marseille va y avoir un manifeste de
marseille qui va être publié l'adoption
de motions en lien avec les négociations
internationales en cours qu'est ce que
ça peut faire changer là aussi
ce congrès au niveau des mentalités à
l'international parce que vous lorsque
vous déposez c'est un recours contre
l'état français mais qu'en est il de
manière internationale votre démarche à
ce qu'elle ait suivi à l'étranger
alors donc fait ce recours menées par
ces deux associations et évidemment
c'est un pas en france au niveau
international pour pas oublier que la
france a un impact énorme aussi sur
d'autres hausses du cac et donc par
exemple militons pour la renaissance du
crime des côtes il devant la cour pénale
internationale qui est un texte qu'elle
est notamment récemment divulgué par la
fondation stop et cotisent et qui ont
nous permettrait d'avoir des outils
juridiques devant la cour pénale
internationale pour poursuivre ceux qui
portent atteinte à la biodiversité
notamment par exemple les politiques
menées par jacques herbaut somaro au
brésil sur la déforestation de la forêt
amazonienne briller encore énormément de
choses qu'ils doivent écouteurs bouger
au niveau international et c'est
convention sur la biodiversité font
évidemment une manière de montrer la
voie politique aux états et pour qu'il y
a un effet d'engouement internationale
pour agir véritablement pour la
protection de la nature merci marine
qu'elle met d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association de défense de
l'eau de l'environnement wild légal